bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique l'émission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation
exfiltrer les cadres les patrons et
leurs familles du bourbier ukrainien eh
bien c'est la mission confiée à notre
invité elie khoury dirige la société
impala filiale du groupe bibelots
spécialisé dans la sécurité des biens et
des personnes bonjour elie khoury
première question est-ce que vous pouvez
nous nous dire en quoi consiste votre
entreprise votre société
impala est une société de conseil dans
la gestion du risque filiale du groupe
bible aux qui est un groupe de sécurité
privée alors justement à titre personnel
elie khoury je crois que vous connaissez
bien de l'ukraine vous y étiez quelques
jours avant le début de la guerre c'est
ça exactement nous sommes rentrés de
kiev ya quelques jours et puis nous
connaissons très bien le pays pour y
avoir perdu des membres de notre famille
alors c'est en tant que professionnel de
l'intelligence économique que vous
agissez là en quoi consistent ces
opérations où vous allez aider des gens
des patrons des cadres a quitté
l'ukraine alors ça commence par déjà
apporter une écoute ses dirigeants qui
sont parfois démunies sous les bombes et
puis pour certains d'entre eux
participaient à les évacuer alors
justement comment vous choisissez vos
clients est ce que c'est des gens vous
aviez avant dans votre portefeuille de
clientèle ou 6,7 des gens qui se
manifeste aujourd'hui pour quitter
rapidement l'ukraine
90% d'entre eux se sont manifestés avec
le début des bombardements
et vous leur aviez dit qu'il fallait
quitter l'ukraine avant le début de la
guerre c'est ça oui oui ça fait cela
faisait plusieurs mois que nous les
avons courage y ont à prendre toutes les
mesures pour petit à petit sortir du
pays alors concrètement aujourd'hui
combien ne sont pas sortis du pays avant
le début et combien vous avez des
personnes à sortir du pays je dirais 100
% d'entre eux ne sont pas sortis avant
et puis aujourd'hui nous sommes sur une
30% serait sortie est encore beaucoup
sont sur place alors comment vous
procéder concrètement vous êtes une
société française et présent
physiquement sur place où vous
travaillez avec des partenaires agir
dans un pays comme celui ci nécessite de
travailler avec beaucoup de monde un
réseau de confiance il est impossible de
croire que qui que ce soit peut agir
seul en ukraine alors qu'ils sont vos
partenaires justement
alors en fonction des localisations des
profils de nos clients nous sommes
amenés à parler avec toutes les parties
prenantes
alors ce sont des sociétés
d'intelligence économique avec qui vous
étiez déjà en partenariat ou ce sont de
nouvelles sociétés vous êtes découvert à
l'occasion de son conflit nous ne
découvrons personnes à l'occasion du
conflit nous travaillons avec plusieurs
sociétés tricolores qui sont très connus
et en fonction des lieux nous sommes
amenés à solliciter d'autres partenaires
étrangers pour être bien clair et licour
évidemment vous ne prenez pas parti dans
ce conflit dont cette problématique
politique n'ont aucunement et vous êtes
en contact avec les deux parties
alors il ya plus que deux parties en
ukraine et à l'intérieur de chaque
partie il y a les différents groupes je
vous donne juste l'exemple par exemple
des tchétchènes on parle des tchétchènes
comme étant un groupe uniforme agissant
alors que il ya plusieurs groupes
plusieurs actions plusieurs coloration
et je pense que c'est valable pour
toutes les parties prenantes
mais alors par exemple vous êtes en
contact évidemment avec les russes c'est
ça
pourquoi ces contacts parce que c'est
des autres contacts historique et puis
parce que dans certains lieux il serait
plus que fou de croire que on pourrait
arriver à une solution sans dialogue
et où sont essentiellement vos clients
vous devez exfiltré plutôt à kiev plutôt
à l'aise plus tôt à l'ouest alors
la majorité et à kiev
et puis bah sur toute l'ukraine
notamment sur des zones qui sont qui
sont sous bombardements
comment vous procéder concrètement vous
envoyer des hommes des voitures pour
pouvoir les exfiltrer
chaque situation est vraiment unique on
essaye d'analyser
la réalité du terrain qui est
extrêmement mouvant échangeant donc les
il est impossible de donner une réponse
globale et unique généralement c'est ce
sont des solutions qui
qui sont manoeuvrés avec les différents
les différents les différents points que
vous évoquiez
personne ne sort uniquement à pied
personne ne sort uniquement en train
personne ne sort uniquement en voiture
c'est une conjonction de plusieurs le
pousseur événement est ce que je veux
dire c'est que vous pilotez leur sortie
où vous envoyer concrètement des hommes
les aider à sortir notre travail est
d'organiser tout cela
c'est à dire que vous parfois il ya des
antilles sa campagne
souvent il ya des personnes qui les
accompagnent pour me dire non ils sont
accompagnés et ils sortent par ouvert où
il ya plusieurs lieux de sortie en
fonction des zones où on est mais et la
plupart veulent rejoindre le flanc ouest
et sortir en europe donc vous avez vu
que les russes souhaitaient aussi qu' il
puisse sortir soit par la russie soit
par la biélorussie est ce que là c'est
un conseil que vous donnez à vos clients
ou pas de partir par ces routes là là
encore tout dépend du profil de chaque
client mais me serais on serait dans
l'erreur de croire que
il y a un côté qui serait
fondamentalement plus dans plus
dangereux que l'autre
bien que je comprenne la configuration
actuelle mais quand on est par exemple à
kharkov je crois qu'il est très délicat
de faire tout un trajet et traverser
tout pays
et puis pour pour terminer sur cette
question
chaque parti a un intérêt à montrer
qu'elle traite bien
les personnes qui avaient qu'elle
accompagne à la sortie donc vous vous
avez réussi à exfiltrer des gens qui
faisait partie de l'opposition
russe en ukraine et via aussi à un
travail avec la russie pour laisser
passer ces gens c'est cela on a eu de
très belles surprises en effet alors
comment ça s'est passé
mon doigt on a discuté on doit on doit
étudier chaque profil l'objectif premier
est d'éviter des surprises c'est à dire
des personnes armées ou des personnes
qui cacheraient des choses plus on
arrive à être transparent avec tous les
partenaires plus on arrive à des
solutions dans l'intérêt de nos clients
il ya des demandes de clients qui
dépasse vos compétences il ya pardon est
ce qu'il ya des demandes de clients qui
dépassent votre compétence il il ya des
demandes qui sont qui sont ils sont
difficiles à manoeuvrer
typiquement vous l'évoquiez un petit peu
quand on est opposant à tel ou tel camp
de façon ouverte et marquer
forcément
les discussions sont plus délicates on
vous a demandé aussi d'aller récupérer
des documents de société et ça vous avez
refusé c'est cela oui la priorité
aujourd'hui d'accompagner les personnes
et non pas ce qui pourrait avoir laissé
derrière cela un des documents cela
inclut de l'argent des bijoux la
priorité aujourd'hui de préserver
l'intégrité physique de nos clients est
alors des clients sont plutôt
disciplinés ou page je crois savoir que
ils ont du mal à éteindre leur téléphone
portable mais pas être repéré
des gens qui sous les bombardements dans
un train de nuit alors qu'il fallait pas
voilà se mettait en ligne et diffuser
des photos sur instagram
est bon
vous imaginez que quelqu'un c'était
délicat ce genre de comportement donc il
est clair que vos clients laissent
derrière eux leur entreprise est-ce que
parmi les services vous pouvez aussi
leur donner des informations sur l'état
des bâtiments par exemple de leur
entreprise où vous avez complètement
évacuée cette question
c'est pas des éléments sur lesquels l'on
agit aujourd'hui la priorité et comme je
voulais 10 et de d'aider à les mettre en
sécurité le reste malheureusement à
partir du moment où la bière s'est
déclenchée nous sommes dans le préjudice
est évalué la portée du préjudice
ce sont des questions
comment dire qu'ils ne sont pas
prioritaires
jusqu'où accompagne et vous vos clients
jusqu'à une frontière roumanie pologne
etc ou encore beaucoup plus loin par
exemple sur la destination qui divise
la destination peut être importante je
vous donne le cadre d'une personne qui
devait se faire opérer pour une mallette
très très grave en ukraine forcément
aujourd'hui c'est compliqué et puis il a
réussi à s'organiser dans un autre pays
et à l'étranger et notre objectif est de
l'accompagner le plus loin possible en
respect des lois et des recommandations
de place alors vous dites est également
unique au riz que vous travaillez avec
vos concurrents en bonne intelligence
pour sortir d'ukraine vovo cadres parce
que c'est le cas je dois je dois
vraiment saluer tous les acteurs de
lieux qui ont une capacité sur place
dans l'eure dans l'eure
dans leur antre aide parce que notre
priorité aujourd'hui n'est pas de faire
de l'argent
sur un conflit qui causent déjà beaucoup
de douleur à tout le monde mais vraiment
de participer à aider le maximum de
personnes et et ça passe par
des deux départs de travailler avec
toutes les personnes qui peuvent qui
peuvent agir sur place donc clairement
et puis même rang de hordes de la guerre
nous essayons de travailler en bonne
intelligence avec toutes les personnes
merde qui a dit merci elie khoury pour
vos réponses l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique est terminée
évidemment vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission sur france 24 points comme au
revoir
[Musique]